[Music]
look at that this frightening video
shows an avalanche barreling towards
snowmobilers in utah saturday
one of the snowmobilers you see had to
dig his brother out of the snow
they are okay but others have not been
so lucky lately
14 people died in avalanches in the u.s
in just the past week the most for any
seven day period in more than a
century 21 people have been killed so
far this winter just two fewer than all
of last winter
as carter evans reports experts warn
that avalanches
could soon become even more
unpredictable
i'm out i got you this snowmobiler cell
phone video captures his desperate
attempt to climb
out of the snow after an avalanche
saturday it barreled down this slope in
utah's
uinta mountains
no one was hurt but they say it was a
miracle everyone made it out alive
i heard hunter yelling and here he is
you okay bud on the same day four skiers
died
in another avalanche in mill creek
canyon utah
four survivors dug themselves out and
were flown to safety
they're the latest in a slew of
devastating avalanches in the u.s
three died last week in alaska and four
were killed over the last several days
in colorado in two separate slides
carl burkland studies avalanches he says
climate change is
complicated efforts to predict when and
how these slides can happen
in an area today for example where we
tend to always see dry snow avalanches
we might see more wet snow avalanches
and this really creates challenges for
avalanche forecasters and for others who
work to mitigate avalanche danger for
the public
his advice get the proper forecast gear
and training
before you hit the slopes for cbs this
morning
i'm carter evans that's very good advice